الزبيده زوجه اسير مصابا بالسرطان في سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تشارك في كل فعاليه
تضامنيه مع الاسرى انها قلقه جدا بعد
التهديدات التي اعلنها وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي
بحرمان الاسرى من العلاج وحتى الاستحمام
والحصول على الماء نوجه اليوم رساله الى
كل الجهات المعنيه بشؤون الاسرى الى
الجهات الحكوميه الرسميه بضروره التدخل
الفوري والعاجل من اجل الضغط على ادارات
السجون
للحد من هذه الاجراءات القمعيه والتعاسفيه
التي يواجهها اسرانا وايضا بهدف انهاء ما
يسمى بالاعتقال الاداري
والافراج عن الاسرى الخاصه الاسرى المرضى
مرضى السرطان
الوزير بن جفير المتهم من مؤسسات حقوقيه
في قضايا ارهابيه وجنائيه اعتبر ان الاسرى
الفلسطينيين يتمتعون بحياه الرفاهيه بدا
بفرض عقوبات تمس ابسط مقومات الحياه
الانسانيه هي اقل حتى مما اوجبه القانون
الدولي في التعامل مع الاسرى بهدف تقويد
الحياه الجماعيه والانسانيه للحركه
الاسيره وكما يؤكد الاسرى الاعتداء على
منجزات وحقوق اساسيه انجزوها بعد نضالات
واضرابات صعبه على مدار عقود
نمط الحياه الجماعي
المجسد على شكل الهيئات واطر وتشكيلات
تنظيميه واعتقاليه نجح من خلالها الاسرى
في ان ياخذوا هذا المسمى الحركه الوطنيه
الاسيره لان هذه الاطر والتشكيلات هي التي
ترعى كل العمليات التثقيفيه وعمليه البناء
والعمليه النضال هذا هو المستهدف اسرائيل
تريد ان تتعامل مع الاسرى كاسراد
واعلنت الحركه الاسيره انها ستواصل التصدي
للاجراءات الانتقاميه حتى الاول من رمضان
وهو اليوم المحدد لبدء اضراب شاملا عن
الطعام تحت شعار الحريه او الشهاده
الاسرى خط احمر والمس بهم يعني شراره
جديده للانفجار هذا ما يؤكده الفلسطينيون
باختلاف اطيافهم وهم يرفضون اي تنازل عن
حقوق اساسيه للاسرى انتزعوها من سجانيهم
الجزيره من امام سجن جلبوع في منطقه بيسان